two rounds are in the books for the 2013
GM and IM norm tournaments here in st.
Louis so far we've had plenty of this
size of games first in the Grandmaster
filled half of the competitors are
gridlocked at the top the eventual
winner will take home one thousand
dollars Grandmaster dennis burroughs of
hungary is playing for the second
consecutive year today he took down
favorite Anatole by kofsky with black
I'm looking for I'm inspired by young
talents and it's fun to play them I mean
we will play exciting games and I hope
to contribute some hopefully not on the
losing side but at least play some
interesting games and if we play some
interesting games they can learn from
that even if they lose so this was
played against behove ski I was black it
was a kind of a strange English
variation and seemingly white is doing
okay but surprisingly I sacrificed my
bishop pair and but for in compensation
I just died all of his pieces um I mean
this came as a shock for white cos it
looked really normal and nice but
unfortunately for him he can't really
defend all of his pieces because the e2
is hanging the c3 is hanging the e3
bishop is hanging and it's kind of
unusual because i have only two pieces
attacking three simultaneously so
somehow he could still defend you lost
the pawn but still trying to muddy
waters trying to
Oh trick me but so after E this was
interesting I mean I'm i still have an
exposed queen um some weaknesses but I
have really active pieces like Bishop e6
though I originally wanted bishop age
five cuz now night see one isn't that
good because we nee five takes root d8
Queen f4 and rugby to problem is that my
queen and Brooke is just killing white
position and I just take the bishop and
I can't take it because if there's a
piece but my rejected this because
surprisingly can play root K 1 which
wouldn't work cuz night takes be three
rook takes a two night d 2 and okay I'm
two pounds up the problem is that my
night is trap so you can play G for
attacking the Bishop Bishop g6 and
Bishop c1f Bishop e3 the nite nite be
one and I fork and I'm winning but yes
Bishop see one night be one rupee three
and unfortunately this night is trapped
and even though I'm a few pounds oh my
still have some problems so I rejected
this this way I played we should be six
they've 94 he tries to activate his
pieces rightly so because he's a pound
down he needs to find some compensation
I'm coming back because my queen was
stupid on a two I just took the pawn
that I'm going back home now he played
efore Queen B 6 engage 1a5 late look III
I could play a 4 immediately I didn't
want to play a four because why rush
with it but it's not necessary that bad
Queen B for Queen Bishop city queen b 6
he could play Bishop b2 but I can still
play for if I want but I mean it was
time trouble so he got a bit frustrated
that mom he's a pawn down and it's the
same position so and we're getting
closer to time control so he just
deviated a 4 but unfortunately this will
end up to be a trouble took it took I
think she
rookie one we see 5 f 4 um why could
take but I just take and he loses the
bishop there that was somehow a bit
compensating in the position but now he
would be just a found down so you play
that for took a five Roxy to between the
one I took 65 Quincy for rookie you want
brocade 594 there's a neat trick for
wipe though maybe just waiting although
I'm I should be much better but if some
reason I would take you would have this
I mean it's not best but this would be
an oh sorry Baba it's like is 328i fix
and rukia it would make the steaks and
sexist mates so there were many options
to lose it from a winning position so
plain ig4
kingi one it's the same years ago I'm
different
Green 823 check you move the pink
because Bishop d four losses for print
XD for the night of thing and it's
losing engage one Queen f2 who should be
too and neither three is a nice move all
of my pieces hanging check linking edge
it because unfortunately for him there's
no way to stop Queen takes h2 that's
made in the International Master field
angelo young of the philippines is in
clear first with black angelo defeated
Caterina nemcova the eventual winner of
this section takes home seven hundred
and fifty dollars the st. Louis classic
goes through november 27th remember to
subscribe to our youtube channel for
these daily updates stl chess club and
of course follow the games live at us
chest champs com